[Music]
[Applause]
minus one what are the new powers of
Godzilla minus one FYI Tokyo had
released its final teaser and in 2 weeks
from now the movie will be seen in
cinemas all over Japan well actually on
the 1st of November in the Tokyo
International Film Festival and then on
the 3D all over Japan yesterday the 18th
was the world premiere in Japan where
the cars the director producers and a
Godzilla Effigy walked down the red
carpet towards the first time they will
actually see the movie for themselves in
a screen for your information the red
carpet that Godzilla was rolled out in
was 50.1 M long stated to be the
official size of the Gman as we had
predicted in earlier
videos he is 50.1 M or
164.jpg pristine and the movements the
framework and all that is just topnotch
imagine all that on a budget of only $15
million just for comparison Godzilla
xcong the new Empire is expected to have
a budget of over $200 million minus one
is working on 7.5% of the monster's
allocated funding for that movie and it
will rival and give gxk a run for its
money literally this CGI is just super
and compared to the MCU movies the CGI
which which are for not lack of a better
word Hollywood look and listen and
look and learn so let's go on frame by
frame the teaser we start with the first
scene showing Godzilla putting his foot
down on the rubble I'm guessing this is
after the explosion whether it is from
Godzilla's new Atomic breath power that
creates a nuclear explosion on impact or
it's from an atom bomb is yet Unknown by
the way the folks from dangerville doing
great work as always notice this strange
new power of Godzilla and called it the
atomic blast which we will also continue
to do so anyway in this scene you can
see the brownish skin of Godzilla
actually shedding away just above the
foot on the ankle of the Kaiju feet so
this confirms that the blast is an atom
bomb delivered by the US to kill
Godzilla but actually served another
Sinister purpose and that is
transforming him into the darker black
minus one version this might actually be
the source of all the rumors of there
being two Godzillas and in reality being
just one who was was transformed by the
radiation and heat from the atom bomb so
we see the same scene afterwards and
then the next one is a new one Godzilla
using his tail to play baseball with
Japanese people as practice as you can
see he's just a bit taller than the
tallest buildings in Tokyo at that time
in the 1950s or late' 40s which confirms
and actually cements down his size to be
50 m or 164 ft tall and just after that
we see a strange new feature never ever
seen before in any earli Godzilla
whether Toho or American this is what we
will lovingly call the god axe but
whether it is an axe like head on the
tip of the tail turning into a
formidable weapon of mass cutting or
it's actually him evolving new dorsal
plates after the atom bomb explosion is
up to debate personally although this
God axe scene looks great such a thing
would not serve a purpose in minus one
uh if it was in the monsterverse however
then wo K will have to stop practicing
swing bringing that Ax better then there
are further scenes of Godzilla walking
in Tokyo and causing Havoc actually
heading towards the train station to
have a bit of a snack then this quickly
shifts to the Seas where at some point
in the movie Godzilla actually Retreats
back to the ocean and then the task
force that is formed to tackle him and
learn about him actually encounters the
kaju in the Open Seas which is 100 times
more frightening than seeing him on land
as he is a primarily aquatic monster
that can outswim any human vessel as
seen in the earlier TV spots but then I
have to admit his dorsal plate
coloration and the glow does resemble
the most of us Gojira in many ways maybe
it's just the white and blue glow maybe
the god axe has a similar shine just
like Kong's axe hey it's just an
observation and then in the last scene
we see Godzilla actually swimming after
a patrol boat with a person at the back
firing 50 caliber rounds at him and he
doesn't even Flinch or blink he kind of
looks like a cat stalking and playing
with an injured Mouse knowing very well
he can kill the people in that boat at
any given moment he chooses to I think
this will happen after Godzilla tackles
the bigger ships that was sent along
with the people to track him down and I
also think that the people there in that
scene will be saved by another ship
shooting at Godzilla from a distance
prompting the Gman to look at the ship
like it did in the last scene of that
teas
like what the hell dude why did you take
that shot and then proceed to dive down
and destroy it with the atomic Bloss an
atomic breath that actually causes a
huge nuclear like explosion on impact
and this scene will also mirror the
scene where Godzilla from the
monsterverse in GVK shoots his Atomic
breath at the aircraft carrier
destroying it and then that's all we
have on this teaser for now in
conclusion this Godzilla from minus one
will be horrific will bring in the
horror elements back to the monster that
has taken our hearts since
1954 so if you like this video then
check this one as well and if you're
more interested in other movie monsters
and creatures then check out our Channel
as well we might just have things that
you haven't seen or thought about like
subscribe and we'll see you on the next
video take care fam